hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to set up
for a peripheral iv
before performing any nursing skills you
want to make sure that you're following
your hospital's protocols
to ensure you're following the latest
guidelines
so whenever you gather your supplies you
want to
grab the following first off go with an
iv start kit
that has almost everything that you need
to start an iv
it's going to have your cleansing prep
it may even have the extension tubing
that you will connect to the cannula
this one doesn't
and it'll have the tourniquet some gauze
tape a dressing to secure the iv
and sometimes even a label to put a date
and time in the size of the iv gauge
that you inserted in the patient
then grab a cap or an extension tubing
if it's not included and get your iv
cannula here we have various sizes we
have a 22 gauge
18 gauge and a 20 gauge and how i can
tell what those are is based on their
color
also i have a saline flush because we're
going to use this
to prime our extension tubing plus
it's going to help us check if our iv is
in a vein
and then i have a curos cap to place on
the extension
tubing's cap just to help keep it clean
and a pair of gloves
also you'll want to check the expiration
date on the supplies to make sure that
they're within that time frame so
they're safe to use
and once you're done with that you'll
want to perform hand hygiene and then
prepare your supplies
now whenever you are prepping your
supplies you want to try to keep
everything as sterile as possible
inside its containers until you're
actually ready to use it
but you want to lay it out in a
strategic way because whenever you
actually have that iv
you're really going to only have one
hand whenever you're trying to secure it
put on the access device and everything
like that so over time
you'll get a little rhythm for how you
do this so first what i want to do
is i want to open up the iv starter kit
and most will peel at the end like this
and i'm just going to
keep it like here and grab things out as
i need it
then i'm going to open up the extension
tubing because we're going to need to
prime this with our saline
flush so just going to keep that
here then i'm going to
open up the flush
and this is a pre-filled one and many of
them come with like an air
bubble in it so i need to prime this so
to do that
i'm just going to take this cap off
and pull back a little bit and then just
get the air out
then i'm going to take this saline flush
and i'm going to remove the air out of
my extension tubing
so to do that i'm going to just connect
and twist
this on and i'm going to just
flush that in there and i'm going to
leave it connected
because that's going to help me out
whenever i start my iv and another thing
to help
you out you want to twist off this cap a
little bit
because it's super hard once you have
the iv to get this cap off
while you're trying to connect it to the
iv cannula so always try to remember to
loosen
that up and then just place it back in
the packaging until you're ready to use
it
then you want to open up the actual iv
needle by just pulling that back
and i want to show you something on this
iv needle
so here you're going to hold it here
with your two with your index finger and
your thumb
where we actually go to start it i'm
just going to just pull this cap off
and um you're going to be threading
this cannula plastic part off of this
needle and the needle is actually going
to be
removed it's going to go into the safety
chamber with this white button when you
hit the button
so you just want to make sure that it
easily comes off
and moves because sometimes there could
be glue there that prevents you from
being able to thread it
and then another thing i want to point
out just to show you if you notice the
tip of
this needle notice here that it
ends all the way at the end but your
cannula your plastic cannula ends before
that needle that is really important
because whenever a lot of people go
to stick the vein they will get blood
returned in this chamber here that's
what we're looking for
but whenever they actually go to thread
this end they have difficulty and they
blow the vein
it will not thread in that's because you
have to go in a little bit more
in order to thread this cannula in and
i'm going to demonstrate that whenever i
actually start the iv
but i wanted you to see the whole
reasoning for that because we have that
gap
of where the needle is longer than the
actual plastic
cannula and then lastly what i like to
do
if it comes with a label in it i like to
fill this part out because you can
actually put this part on the iv
to let other nurses know the date you
inserted it
the size you inserted it the type and
then
your initials because hospitals have
protocols for how often these have to be
changed out okay so that wraps up this
video and if you would like to watch
more videos on nursing skills you can
access the link in the youtube
description below